This this all seems to line up, man. It
all tracks.
Obviously, we don't know 100% but it all
it all seems to track.
Who would do that, bro?
Who would do that? What sort of deranged
insane person would do that?
>> [music]
>> Who might have an issue with this Chad?
Who do you think might have a problem
with this? I don't think they'll be
calling in somehow.
So this [__] is nothing to me, bro.
Bro, I'm crying.
This [__] nothing to me, bro.
But yeah, the falling out with Chad
yesterday.
Maybe it's not New Year's.
Maybe it's not a New Year's stream.
[music]
Maybe it's you.
This might be too personal.
But text about being hurt and bleeding
after sex.
OH, DUDE.
OH, OH, DEEP PROBLEM with a very
compelling point here.
I don't think it's okay to lie to ugly
used up women.
Well, after considering. Oh, okay okay.
Okay. Okay okay. Okay, I guess we're
doing this. I guess we're doing this.
I really don't have much evidence
because he was so careful and told me
all of this was normal.
Like we don't need to do it three times
in one day or do it so hard I hurt and
bleed.
Three times in one day.
What dude?
That seems like a lot, man.
Like I you know I don't dude I don't
want to get too like precise, okay?
But like
friction is a thing. I mean like you
know
how do we put this? How do we put this,
okay?
If you're going to you know
put your pipe into the waterworks, okay?
Dude, you might be able to slide it in
reasonably the first time. But as time
goes on, you might need to get some
mechanical lubrication. Is that like a
way I can put it? Like do you know what
I mean?
Like I don't want to be too precise
about it cuz it's gross but you know
what I'm saying, right? You know what
I'm saying.
And on top of that as well, three times
a day is an excessive amount in my
perspective. Yeah, listening to this
like
if you're in some sort of early stage of
Unk trying to describe this in like
[__] teenager terms to a bunch of
virgins in chat. I said dude this is
rough. This is rough to listen to. Just
say just say can we not just let's just
be straight down let's just you know
straight down the middle.
If you're going to do it that much, you
probably need lube. Just can we
we just we can just say it like that. We
can just say it like that.
We don't have to do this [__]
dancing around the topic.
You know like as if we as if we can't
talk about it.
It's it's right the messages are right
there. The the
anyone with an IQ above 75
knows what's happening here.
Yeah, if I put WD-40 in the exhaust.
Shut up, man. Shut up.
relationship, I think it's normal that
you have more of like that kind of
relationship. But three times a day is a
lot, okay? That is a lot.
Okay, anyway. Crying emojis.
Or do it so hard I hurt and bleed.
Oh, dude.
Oh.
>> [laughter]
>> Sometimes you use the pump shotgun three
times in a match, might just find some
[__]
That is how Chad talks about sex.
Unironic that is.
Bro, it's so true. Good lord. Good lord,
bro. [laughter] Oh, man. Oh, dude. I
can't, man. This is oh.
This is just insane.
Well, if you don't want to have sex, we
don't got to. We can do other things.
Bro that's [laughter] no way, man.
There's no way, dude.
Okay, I like doing other things, too. Oh
my god, bro.
Yeah, sorry that I've torn up your
snatch like pulled pork. How about you
just suck me off instead next time?
Now you got to respect that. You got to
respect that.
This is [laughter]
this is nuts, bro.
Okay, anyway.
You do got to respect that. Could be
worse, okay? Could be worse. But
that's right that's a rough read. That
is a rough read, okay?
That is a rough read.
Um was the student him being either
uncaring or aggressive during sex or was
this a health issue you had? I have no
health issue that I know of. Never bled
during sex before.
It was the aggression. Just gave into it
after a while and told him I liked it
but I bled after almost every single
time.
Oh, dude.
There's something amiss there, dude. You
need you need to go and get that looked
at cuz that doesn't sound right to me,
okay? Dude.
You need to you need to go and have a
little
have a little look at what's going on
there. That seems a little bit rough,
okay?
Anyway, continuing on.
Continuing on.
Did he ever give you any sort of
aftercare or did he just expect you to
get over it yourself?
Bro dude, come on. Give me strength,
dude.
We'll just go on his phone on Discord
after literally choking, hitting, and
making me bleed lol.
Bro, really? Really? I'm supposed to be
outraged about that presumably. Guys,
[__] it.
>> [laughter]
>> Come on, dude. Give me give me a break,
man. That's crazy work.
That's dude. That [laughter]
is wild, man.
Sorry, I've got some loser creeps and
pedos to catch up on, okay? The toilet's
that way, [__]
The toilet's that way, [__]
Oh, man. This is oh. Come on. Focus,
guys. Come on.
Had to teach him how to be nice after.
This was an issue at the beginning. I
believe the bleeding was caused because
he would basically just bend me over,
choke me, and stick his dick into me
basically.
Katie had the same story reaching out to
me. Yo, they gave you 50 sec. Thank you.
How can you be in a relationship with
someone you obviously can't even talk
to? People are so insane.
Um
yeah. I mean can't argue.
What's she saying about Tom being you
know impossible to talk to and stupid as
[__] is um pretty true though.
I can imagine that.
I can totally see that.
and helpful in understanding how bad
this all really was because I only had
told my roommate after one time that it
was pretty rough.
Okay.
How do I dude?
There there's something there is
something amiss here. I don't you know I
don't want to act like I'm you know like
it's funny to laugh at some of this. But
like
obviously you you've dude
um Okay, dude how do I put it this dude?
You you can't just go in like that,
okay?
Like
there's physiology, okay? There's
physiology. No no no, it's not it's not
big [__] Tom, okay? That's not what it
is.
It's The people in chat were so
[__]
It's like so it's like
they're so [__] man.
attentive lover. Can I put it like that?
Is that is that enough to get the point
across?
No, you're not understanding. Bent me
over and [__] me. The implication
here, okay?
Guys, the implication here is is not to
do with the dynamics of of the sex. It
is It's not because Chad is being quiet.
I'm sorry. If you can't interpret the
[__] details here
on your own, you're a [__] [__]
You're like [__] you must like 15 or
something like unironically.
It's
he's not doing enough initially, okay?
Like he's going in dry. He's going in
dry. I don't know how else to put it to
you [__] virgins, bro. He's going in
dry.
He's not you know
teeing up, okay? Like how else do I have
to [__] say it, bro?
[__] me, bro.
It dude, come on.
There must be some people that have had
sex in this [__] chat, bro. You must
know what I mean.
Bro, [clears throat] licking the poon
poon. Dude, let's just say that seems
like the last thing on his mind, okay?
That seems like the last thing they're
even thinking about here, dude. Amazing
virgin film I would imagine, Steve.
Turkey is famous for being dry. Yes,
exactly. I hate I literally I hate
seeing Chad's chat is on in topics like
this, man. It's literally it makes you
want to [__] bash your head against
the wall. Bro, come on. Like look, I'm
not going to talk about in detail cuz
it's [__] deranged but you know let's
just say that there needs to be
um a level of like balance. It's like
Stylo talking sense in the most deranged
way possible and then just to save
Continuing on. Continuing on.
So this is apparently the other ex left
for dead, okay?
Okay, wait wait wait wait wait. I've got
it. The turkey must be basted, okay?
You've got to baste the turkey. There we
go. Perfect. Nice one, man. All right,
let's come up with a bunch of [__]
New Year's resolutions, okay?
Let's continue on. that'll make it
simpler.
Hi, finally made an account. Yes, Tom is
extremely harsh during sex. I've been
down the kink road in my life and how he
acts is actually just evil and almost
sadistic.
Not even kinked up.
Just actually a Patrick Bateman type
gooner.
Oh my god, dude. Please give me
strength. I flip between oh, that sounds
really rough and then they describe him
in a way that I just have to respect. I
just have to immediately respect that,
bro.
First got to already posted some of my
screenshots but if anyone has questions
or wants specific proof, I'll try to see
if I can answer.
Has Tom attempted to reach out to you
since you've been registered and get
first posted? I told him I was
considering reaching out to law
enforcement.
Okay, for what? Rough sex? I mean even
if he's taking it to an extreme, I'm I'm
a bit skeptical. What the [__] do you
want law enforcement to do?
Oh, he slapped me about a bit during
sex. I mean did you want it or not? I
don't know, dude.
Telling people about everything that
went down and then I blocked him after
listing out every single thing he did
wrong because I know he will send my
text to his lawyer.
Um he also he also said how it was
awesome I looked like a little girl the
first time we had sex.
Oh. Um
yeah, dude.
I don't know, man. I can totally I can
totally see I can totally see this.
Obviously not proven, no way to
understand, no.
Both of these girls are saying that he
makes comments like this, it seems. Kai
was an age player,
it seems.
This This all seems to line up, man. It
all tracks.
Obviously we don't know 100%, but it all
it all seems to track.
You know, and again, I can't stress that
it's whatever it it's whatever on its
own, but it's the fact he's such a
[__] poser.
Starting to feel a little uncomfortable.
I'm not going to lie, dude.
Oh, I think feel like something a bit
amiss. Feel like the temperature's
getting a bit too hot in my room, bro.
It's getting a little bit uncomfy.
Anyway, obviously no proof.
There are a number of
Okay.
One thing to point out,
and again, I'm open-minded about this,
but these two have communicated, and
there is the trend of women
communicating and sort of aligning
stories in ways that can make it sound
worse, okay? So,
I'm just trying to be fair. This all
This does look real pretty [__]
rough, dude. This does look pretty
rough.
But I would like some evidence of some
some nature in order to really back this
up, you know?
And the problem you've got as well,
okay?
Dude, bro. Dude, as much as Creamen
hates commentary, right? He is so
commentary brained, it's unbelievable.
The worst part of this IS THE HYPOCRISY.
>> [laughter]
>> OH MY GOD, [laughter] DUDE. OH, YOU WERE
JOKING. DUDE, I thought you were
serious, bro. Dude, you got me. You got
me, dude. I thought [laughter] you were
joking. I thought you were serious.
That is so based, dude. I thought
>> [laughter]
>> That would be a banger, though.
Um Turkey Tom has made a video talking
about someone being a gooner, and he's a
gooner himself. Talk about hypocrisy.
Okay. Anyway, continuing on.
Dude, I didn't know, bro. Listen, I'm
autistic. You guys are going to have to
start putting in 10 S or whatever behind
your messages so I know, in order to
avoid getting one guide, okay? It's
rough out there. It's rough out there.
It's rough out there, too. I was AFK,
but I I did hear that.
I didn't read that message earlier.
I mean, like look, yeah. I mean,
obviously it is like, bro, you make I'm
crying.
>> The problem is is like, it you're
getting it the wrong way around. You're
getting it the wrong way around, okay?
Here's Here's the thing,
right? The issue is not he's a gooner
whilst calling other other people
gooners. The issue is, what does he
think and how does he respond to people
talking about this, okay? Because he
would, you know, if you rolled in the
mud if you rolled in
What's A [__] GREAT, BRO? PIGS PIGS
PIGS PIGS PIGS. If [laughter] you roll
in the mud, you're going to get dirty.
Pigs Pigs Pigs Pigs
Hey, man.
Okay?
So, Tom absolutely rolls in the mud with
this stuff. So, as long as he is willing
to accept, you know, it's his turn to
get dirty, then so be it, right?
But at the end of the day, as long as
he's willing to accept that, I don't
really think there's what I mean by it's
the wrong way around. It's like, he can
call out people to blow in the face
about whatever he wants, as long as when
it's his time, it's like, okay, fair
enough. Fair's fair, right? Fair's fair.
>> [snorts]
>> And And yeah, like I'm not doing the
Tipster song now, but yeah, he obviously
went super hard at Tipster and stuff
like that, like It's not It's not the
hypocrisy point for me. It's more so,
how do you handle it when it's your time
when it's your turn in the controversy
spotlight? And it's like you've got to
just take it with with grace. And
obviously responding to it if he wants
to,
you know, pointing out his perspective
on it is reasonable, and I would
probably want to see if he responds to
what he said about it.
But I mean, yeah, it's just the nature
of the beast.
Dude, yes, Lady Swifington.
Sometimes you're the hammer, sometimes
you're the nail. That is a prevailing
sentiment in this this little this
little content creation industry, okay?
So, let's let's put it that way.
You can't put the entrails back in the
turkey, true. Okay, anyway.
Anyway, he also he also said how it was
awesome I look like a little girl for
the first time we had sex. Told me he
was excited to learn I BPD. Shut the
[__] up because girls with it loved
harder, lol, so [__]
Okay, dude.
Okay, bro, that sounds a bit rough, but
The thing is, we don't know if the phone
without consent happened. There isn't
really good evidence for it. I totally
agree that that is like beyond [__]
If he was actually like, you know,
regardless of whether unless it's
pre-negotiated,
regardless of whether they sort of like
don't really care in the end, even
broaching that, you're [__] You're
[__] And if [__]
Pulling out your phone midway, just
yeah.
However, we just really don't have good
evidence for it.
Um
So, it I mean, we'll just see.
We'll just see.
See what his response is.
But again, I am reserving the
conclusions. Let's continue.
Preferably you should drop everything
you have on him. I got to upload
everything from my phone to my PC.
I got a crazy audio of him saying he
wants to night rape me.
>> [laughter]
>> Which for short, think he was saying
that as like negative rizz, but actually
insane to use that as rizz.
Bro.
If you don't want to get night raped,
you got to sleep on the couch, [__]
okay?
Listen, my my bed is my domain.
And I I what
I mean, it is just it does just seem
like it's, you know,
rizzing.
It does just seem like it's just like
flirt this like kind of half-ironic
flirting.
You know?
Like he's probably interested in some
kind of CNC stuff,
and he's saying like,
you know, the rape is like a
joking flirting way of broaching it
almost.
>> [laughter]
>> Primus noctis, is that what it is? In my
bed, which is my domain. I reserve the
right to primus noctis.
Okay?
What made you turn on him? Obviously
he's done some [__]
But what moment was it that made you
decide [__] this?
I just truly thought he was a cringe
F'sler who Def was going to beat me
later if I stayed around.
We only had a 2-month fling because even
my insane ass was scared of how he
acted, and he also was just stupid, and
I hated conversation with him.
Dude, okay. The other thing I will say
as well, okay, to be to be fair to Tom
here, is
obviously the way you frame or describe
something can make it sound a certain
way, okay?
And it could be that there's some sort
of like BDSM dynamic here, and at the
time that was encouraged or like that
was what the nature of the conversation
was.
And now you read it in the cold light of
day,
and you're like,
okay, this looks nuts. But we don't know
what the nature of the conversation was.
Maybe they were into that.
>> could probably have showed you up. Guys,
764 people watching right now.
122 likes on the stream.
Huge amount of people here right now.
Some of those 640, massive amount of
people that have not liked the streams
yet.
Wouldn't mind please moving the cursor
thumbs up and clicking it. Or pressing
the thumbs up on the mobile device.
That'd be huge appreciated.
If you want to take your support one
step further, you can support the stream
directly. Keep the Keep the stream
running. Keep the stream Keep the lights
on
through the stream elements link in the
pin chat message, which will allow you
to donate directly.
You can also buy a membership to the
channel, which are awesome, give you
some some emotes.
You can You can gift memberships to the
channel. Gift one or many randomly
throughout the chat.
You can buy a super chat, which will
highlight a message and read out on TTS.
Or you can buy a super sticker, which is
a YouTube image or GIF. It'll be
highlighted in chat,
and I'll describe it to you.
Uh you can use discord.gg/Creamen,
twitter.com/Creamen, or
reddit.com/r/Creamen. Thank you. Thank
you. Thank you.
Yeah, homies hanging with rats just to
prove they get cheese.
That's That's real, Jim, bro. I'm seeing
that in chat. You know what I mean?
But anyway, just to be fair to all sides
here. Let's continue.
Okay. Um
I truly thought he was a cringe F'sler
who Def was going to beat me later if I
stayed around.
We only had a 2-month fling because even
my insane ass was scared of how he
acted, and he also was just stupid, I
hated conversation with him.
What specifically did he do, and what
proof do you have?
He was just extremely weird to me, and
also evil as [__] during sex. Again, I
only had a small fling with him, and I
would have to fly out to see him, so
luckily I didn't witness a lot, but
enough to tell you guys, and also help
add validity to the statements. Also, I
have random audio recordings in every DM
and text.
Okay.
Yo, thank you, Michiko. Thank you. Huge
appreciated. I think when I get halfway,
I will take a quick break, and then DK
can probably turn this into two
segments, I think.
Okay.
Continuing on.
Um
Okay.
He was Yo, thank you, Pixie Titan, for
the gift membership. Thank you.
Okay.
Um is there any particularly interesting
or damning you'd like to share from
them? I'm turning on my old phone now to
grab the videos, and I'll post whatever
I think is even semi-relevant. Okay, I
was thinking about this yesterday, okay?
I only thing that [laughter] it's only
fair
>> Folded hands emoji. Red heart emoji.
Christmas tree emoji.
Yeah.
That
I can't say it on right now.
No, no, come on. Let's not be silly.
Dude, I I did I did I got to be careful,
dude.
Dude, let's just say that I think that
Turkey Tom when he was joking, I don't
think it was just about the sex, okay?
I think it was like a sort of, you
[__] you're never going to leak on me,
[__] Oh, just squeezing the throat
like that. Just squeezing the life out
of her like a [__] like a chicken
just to make sure she never leaks.
Oh my god, dude. Come on. Come on, lock
him.
I'm turning on my own phone my old phone
now to grab the videos, and I'll post
whatever I think is semi-relevant.
Sacramento mentioned a just in case
folder. Can you confirm corroborate what
what would be in that folder? And do you
know if anything related to you is in
that folder, and what type of material
is in it?
Okay.
No clue. He told me the phone calls,
texts from ex Kai. I'm probably in there
too now. Might be other stuff as well.
Okay, I've got to be honest with you. My
gut instinct with this, the just in case
folder, I don't think that's a blackmail
thing, right? I think that's a like
self-defensive measure, you know? It's
like if you think you're going to be
killed by some authority, you hand a
disc over to someone and say in the
event of my death, I've been
assassinated, put that on the internet,
right? I think that he's probably got
that in case someone, you know,
if he gets put in a self-defense
situation, he's got the ability to
defend himself. That's what I think it
is, you know?
No, I don't think it's a dead man
switch. That would be funny, but I don't
think it's a dead man switch. I think
it's just if an ex tries to come at me,
you know, I've got material to back up
and defend my my position, my kind of
perspective, you know?
No, I don't think it's a goon folder.
Maybe some of it is, but I think this
this re- I mean, you know,
I not that I've got anything like this.
I mean, this is like, you know, like I
think
He's obviously dabbling about quite a
lot if he's thinking he needs a folder
of his exes.
And on top of that as well, I think
he probably also
um
Yeah, and then that kind of covers it
really. I think he's just
No, no, no, no. This is what it is.
Maybe some goon stuff, I don't know.
He's got that there in case someone goes
comes forward with an allegation so he
can defend himself. And I think the fact
that he's thought to do that
there's a level of prudence you want to
engage in obviously, but to me, I think
that speaks to the fact that some of
these women are a bit like unstable and
he's worried that they're going to
[__] drop the nuke on him, you know?
I mean, I don't think it's just that.
So, I think he's
>> There is I feel like I don't usually,
you know, I wouldn't usually like using
the saying, but I feel like there is a
little bit of like
nothing to hide, nothing to fear
about some of this stuff.
Like the fact that you feel the need to
have a
nuking my ex folder
in case she leaks something about you.
Implies that you know there's stuff she
can leak about you that would be
damaging.
You know? It's like
you you obviously know you're [__]
around.
You know you're [__] around.
And here's the thing, man.
I you know, I I can just read people. I
can just read people.
This Turkey Tom guy in one minute. Let's
pull the image up.
Unfortunately, I can just read people's
psychology and I'm I'm totally happy to
just say it even when I can't fully
prove it. So,
you can see let's just quickly analyze
cuz
It's been some great journalism here.
Great great journalism from Salvo.
Here.
Here is Turkey Tom at Anon Bird bragging
about his basement to an ego. She refers
to it as the ego rape dungeon.
Now, the ego rape dungeon is one thing
that could be a reference to CNC.
Now, let's just go through the the
posters here. So, Despicable Me, haha,
funny, you're so ironic and epic. Uh
X-Men 3: The Last Stand.
Terrible choice.
I believe uh
Am I [__] Is that I don't know. Is
that Is that alien or some [__] I don't
I don't even know. I don't know what
poster that is.
But what have we got here, guys? What
have we got here?
These two
tell you everything you need to know.
They tell you
everything
you need
to know
about this guy.
You've got a Death Note poster in your
room
and you've got a The Social Network
poster in your room.
Tell everyone sees you. Anyone who's not
[__]
anyone who's not one of your [__]
you know,
borderline lesbian teenage girl fans
can see through ex- exactly. They can
see you. They can see your soul.
He's like a
giga [__] Yep, just a total empty
poser
who
thinks to himself as oh, I'm like so
smart. I'm like so cunning.
I'm like so cunning. Yeah, I built this
[__] I'm so cunning that I built this
[__] on my own.
[__] you. [__] you.
You're not some [__] edgy awesome
manipulator like Yagami just cuz you
saved your girlfriend's nudes, bro.
Okay?
It ain't that deep. None of this [__]
that serious, bro. Cry. I'm crying.
I'm crying.
effective thing because some of the
women he's been knocking about with have
got some like issues, let's put it that
way.
Anyway, how did you guys meet? Did he
Did he initiate contact with you or vice
versa?
I'd already followed him because I
watched his YouTube low. Then when him
and Kai broke up, he immediately DM'd me
on Instagram and followed me. He also
told me I look like Kai.
And he definitely has some weird issue
relating to her because he still has all
her clothes even after moving multiple
times since they broke up.
Okay, dude.
Okay, man. That's uh
Okay, okay, bro.
>> [laughter]
>> That is okay. Certainly a claim that is
being made, okay?
He certainly is making a claim.
Okay, dude. I see people better than
something. You guys have got to chill,
bro, okay? Look, lock in, okay? Stop
Stop talking about other people.
>> What? It's just like so crazy, man. I'm
sorry. You all have like disabilities,
okay? You have disabilities.
Working Lizard 01 says in chat, his
girlfriends are mostly in their 20s. So,
I literally I can see like two pixels of
your profile picture super zoomed out
and your name
and I already know I just know
immediately.
Just
we understand you're you're in your 20s.
We get it. You're in your 20s.
I we we see we get it. That's not all of
them and it's obviously regardless an
expressive way of describing a young
stupid female audience, not necessarily
saying that specifically his audience is
a huge share of under 18-year-olds. I'm
just I'm literally just
I'm it's obvious I'm being expressive
and hyperbolic there, okay?
going to apply to.
At least so far no smell problems
reported.
No, he does smell. Also, last time I saw
him, he had [__] ringworm low. Right,
okay.
I'm crying. I'm crying.
>> So, guys, we'll just I think like
just
We'll continue with the document in a
sec.
That probably is the the first, I guess,
video. DK, make a note that's the first
video. We're going to milk this and farm
this.
I'd say about
90% I'd say 90% of this is for the sake
of embarrassment and 10% here is
arguably more concerning or worthy of
some criticism, okay?
Like it's just clear so much of this is
just about embarrassing him and you
know, I think that in of itself is a
problem.
Haven't they Haven't these got young
women got shrines to build?
>> Haven't they got shrines like it's like
yeah, I'm going to reveal all the
embarrassing information about this guy.
And also like stuff like this as well.
Oh, he smell. Well, you were with him
for months or 2 months.
I mean, two two month fling while they
obviously weren't together that whole
time that she flew out a couple times. I
don't think that's that crazy even if he
had bad hygiene.
No, he does smell. Also, last time I saw
him, he had [__] ringworm low.
That's rough. That is rough. once in
this case.
Like
isn't that an L on your part?
Like you're you're getting with a stinky
guy. I mean, I don't know, dude. It just
feels like bitter lashing out.
And I think that there is obviously a
BPD element to this
where women that have got these sorts of
conditions
you know, can sometimes lash out like
this and kind of go crazy and and reveal
all this stuff.
Um that being said, I think that it is
probably indicative of Tom's lack of
prudence that
>> [laughter]
>> this is happening, you know?
Not every [__] got BPD. I mean, sure.
And
Okay, wait a second. She literally said
she's got BPD. What do you mean, bro?
She said it. She said it herself.
Okay?
BPD bitter ex. I think there is an
element of that here, you know?
Yeah, but I don't think it's the case.
>> Can we Can we just be realistic here,
okay?
Jord, what are the proof? You treat this
as if it is true, so I must have missed
some evidence. Oh, no, no, not at all.
I'm not saying this is definitively
true. I'm just reading the claims that
are made and I think that whilst I'm
skeptical, I think it would be silly to
think oh, this is all just made up,
right?
Like some of these some of this stuff is
likely to have a basis in in truth.
But obviously, I can't determine that.
And
yeah, I don't know, man.
Like
I'm not saying saying this is all true
and correct. I'm like
some of this stuff there's probably
something there, but I'd like to see
some evidence, okay?
Is this what you're covering today?
Uh yeah, I
as I've said, due to personal stuff, I'm
having to do shorter streams at the
moment. So, I'm going to have to uh to
go in about an hour and a half, I'm
afraid. Oh, skip skipping the quite
quick quit and crash out.
I'll tell you this of
That's all good for you.
the 20th
Yeah, so I can
Boom.
It's related.
It's part two of the coverage of this
document, okay?
And as part of that, it looks like some
calls have been leaked.
Let's have a little look.
Calls. Sent you the videos in DMs. Okay,
so that's the person that's made this is
saying this to me, okay?
So, we've got boosted audio versions. I
think we'll try the the boosted audio
ones. I've just downloaded them.
Here we go. Boosted call one and I'll
open it up with VLC. Here we go.
Let's have a listen.
Can you hear this?
Wait, what was that?
Dude, oh this is bad from Chad. This is
bad. This is bad, dude. What was that?
What was that?
Okay, one sec. Sorry, sorry guys.
Unprofessional. Unprofessional.
Unprofessional. So
They've already said night rape. That
phrase already come up.
>> Unprofessional.
Properties. Sorry, sorry, sorry. I've
got Oh my god, dude. Where is the wee
wee player? There we go. Boom.
Listen, listen, listen, listen. Here we
go. Here we go. Lock it. Lock it, guys.
Um here we go.
Can't wait for Keemstar to make one
tweet about this and say I had to end
another internet friend.
>> Why why do I always have to Why do I
always have to go and kill my friends?
Why do I always have to go
Holy [__] Don't even [__] start.
Don't even make me think about it, dude.
Thank you for the five pounds though.
Thank you. Highly appreciated.
Thank you from the Southside. Highly
highly appreciated for the $20 though.
Pretty much Chad having morals about
this about they're just trying to
embarrass Tom.
Well, that's the formula for his own
content.
Look at this person. I'm going to say
weird. I think the point is breaching
someone's privacy and trust.
The purpose was purpose was purpose of
embarrassing them, right?
Someone you've got a personal
relationship with and they are they
broke his trust.
In a way that is unjustified in order to
embarrass him.
Simply pointing and laughing at, you
know, others' embarrassing situations is
a little is a little bit different. It's
a way lower violation if a violation at
all.
True, true.
True.
Okay.
Okay, so that is the first call.
Apparently there's a transcription.
Oh, night rain. Is he saying night rain?
Oh, I think he's saying he likes playing
night rain, I guess. Okay, that makes
sense. Same character Nick got to call
out Tom b c. No one else does stream.
Crying face emoji.
Being moral and fair is hard.
Thank [snorts] you for the $5, Iro.
Thank you. Highly appreciated.
Dude, it's so bad. Yeah, literally I saw
I saw Stylosa. I was going to correct
him in chat.
And I saw you saying that he's joking.
And I'm like
Okay, I guess I guess he's just doing a
bit. I guess it's like he's saying that
it's night rain as like a bit.
But no, he actually thought they were
saying night rain.
He actually thought they were saying
night rain. He was saying night rain.
Yeah, no I saw you playing along,
Stylosa. I saw.
But yeah, this is
this is nothing anyway.
Like I said many times throughout this
coverage.
Plenty of people sort of joke around for
ironic tongue in cheek like talk about
rape as a standing for sex or use it to
approach different topics of like kinks
of whatever.
You know, you sort of joke around.
It's like not
that crazy. It's not that crazy for this
sort of conversation to happen. People
try and run with it. It's bad optics
when it gets leaked, but
it's not crazy.
I don't Yeah, okay. Okay, well that's
that's Yeah, okay.
Bro.
Okay, dude.
Oh my god, dude. This is so [__]
raped, bro. Okay, we've got it now.
[__] now.
>> [clears throat]
>> True. Actually it's true.
Okay, yeah. You're too strong sometimes.
My little noodle arms I literally was I
thought my arm was going to break at one
point. Okay, so we're talking about
putting weight presumably in some sort
of sexual act.
True. So true. So true. So true.
It's so nice though. It's like cuz like
you're like small and petite and I'm
like big and strong. It's like really
nice couple.
Oh, small and petite. Dude.
Problem? Tom's got Tom's got a type.
Small and petite. Problem? Problem? It's
like a match made in heaven.
>> [laughter]
>> I'm still I'm just Yeah, I'm still
shocked that you like met dudes.
>> [clears throat]
>> So she sat here recording this with her
friend, right?
>> So true.
Okay.
Elf girl from Game of Thrones.
Please provide an image of the elf girl
elf girl from Game of Thrones at once.
Ew. Oh my god.
Oh my god, what's the Oh, what's the
Skins [__] quote? She [__] like a
fairy on acid.
>> [laughter]
>> Uh the show Skins. The like a show about
like Yeah, the British show about like
Okay, so to be clear, there was nothing
of any meaningful substance.
>> Yeah, it's hard to tell whether cuz
here's the thing, right?
I could almost see like the fact that
you're recording this with a friend as
like
an indication you felt like something
was off at the time, but it's hard to
distinguish that from you just being
like some spiteful horrendous person
who's like mocking this guy behind his
back.
Sleep there. I mean the Yeah, this is
We'll see. We'll continue on, okay? I
will continue to
reserve judgment, okay?
But there's a few pieces coming into
play here. There's a few pieces coming
into play with the age play stuff I
mentioned earlier, but that wasn't
really enough for me to just think,
okay.
Some odd comments there. Nothing that
crazy, I don't think. Just feels like
embarrassment more than anything else.
Yeah, those recordings were quite
underwhelming.
Let's continue on.
It is him talking about holding me down
and hurting my arms and me running away.
Also night rape. Ignore Oh!
That Okay. Dude.
>> Right. So apparently that was the first
call. I thought he was talking about
playing night rain.
Which is apparently
um Okay.
You're such an idiot, bro.
Dude. Well, if I'm such an idiot, why so
many people watching me cover this,
dude?
You thought about that?
Did you 4K people watch Keemstar every
night? I don't Dude, I got Dude, I
challenge What do you mean, bro? to to
discern that said night rape. Like it's
[__] wild, dude. Also my ears aren't
what they used to be.
My ears aren't what they used to be,
dude. I'm getting old now. I'm getting
old now. I'm getting old now. I'm
getting old now. I'm getting old, dude.
[__] Suddenly you're raped. I'm so
owned. I'm so raped, bro.
Thank you. Thank you very much for the
kicks. Thank you.
Okay.
Okay, let's let's listen to that one
more time. My apologies. I'll listen to
it again with the new context taken into
account, okay?
>> [clears throat]
>> Oh, okay. Bro, dude. Hang on a sec,
right? Everyone's mad at me for not
hearing night rape, okay? I said night
rain, right? No [__] in chat said, "Oh
no, it's the night rape thing." You're
all like, "Oh yeah, yeah, man. That
sounds about right."
Give me a [__] break, dude, okay?
Holy [__] dude.
No, I I I I seriously [laughter] what I
thought he said.
Anyway, night rape. I mean, dude. Come
on, man.
>> Keemstar wears the costume of an asexual
man for stream. It is really off-putting
at times.
Thank you for the $5, Randy. Thank you.
I Look, it sounds crazy. I don't know
the context of like that short clip.
This woman clearly is just trying to get
dirt on him. Okay? Recording like this
is sneaky as [__]
Okay?
Okay.
Anyway, look. If you think I'm sweeping,
fine.
That's fair enough. I'm sure that some
of you might believe that.
I personally think that
Oh, dude. I don't know. This is
This is bad.
Yeah, but is it though? Like the problem
is is non-consensual [__] like sounds
awful, right? But like I don't know what
their dynamic is, bro.
I don't know what their dynamic is. Like
if they're Maybe she's into that. I
don't [__] know, dude. And maybe he's
getting baited to say something that
sounds horrendous.
It's like, you know, sounds rough, but
um
The the thing the thing is it really
shows lack of Tom has got like a lack of
prudence in talking about night rape
with someone he's in a two-month fling
with.
You know?
But beyond that, it's like yeah. I'm I'm
not Nothing to write home about. Let's
put it that way, okay?
Anyway, continuing on.
Yeah, get your broom emojis out. I'm
sweeping. I'm sweeping. Sorry, what is
the correct reaction to a 13-second clip
of someone talking about night rape?
Am I supposed to be like,
"Oh my god. He wanted to literally pin
her down
in the middle of the night?" Like it's
you know.
There seems to be some BDSM dynamics at
play here, the nature of which I don't
know. The fact it's being recorded
without his knowledge, okay?
Um I'm also a bit like, okay.
Not
not really sure about about Yeah, this
is something to do with with the whole
allegation. That being said,
this does look rough for Tom and I'm
sure it's going to cause like
reputational damage. Damage.
Is anyone really surprised that Chad is
sweeping? Dude, I Dude, bro. I'm not
sweeping, bro.
Dude, I'm not sweeping. I challenge you
to go and find an allegation where
someone has done something like this and
I've been like, "Oh my god, he wants to
rape her."
Give me a [__] break, dude.
Okay?
I'm often skeptical of this sort of
[__]
>> Let's go through some of this. You you
[__] for the clout and to one day
expose him. You're involved
in a lot of other e-drama. The UwU so
small up is pretty cringe. He's way
worse though, lol.
Because I'm so big and strong, okay.
Okay, wait, dude. Wait, hang on.
Wait, he did.
My best friend was at my house and
thought I was a victim from the jump.
He was saying similar stuff, all cool,
so she started recording. At the end of
the night rape, you can barely hear her
whisper, "But you were a victim, lol."
Agree, I was only playing along because
I don't know what else to say.
>> you, 2 seconds. Also,
come up, bro. Give me a No, not
accepting that. That's [__]
I find it incredibly hard to believe.
First of all, right? First of all, I
find it hard to believe that a BPD woman
isn't into rape play, okay? Let's get
that clear straight away. Let's get that
one out of the way, okay?
No [__] way, dude. Absolutely not.
[__] bro.
And secondly,
the idea that she is just playing along,
right? To me, it's likely that there is
some sort of prior conduct or behavior
that she's engaged in that has made Tom
comfortable enough
to actually do it, right? I don't think
it's like straight away. Should Tom be
more prudent? Yes, obviously, right?
There's clearly issues with trusting
these women, you know, like it to to say
things which would be catastrophic if it
came out cuz people might judge her
harshly, sure, okay? But this idea she
was just playing along sounds [__]
She sounds like a BPD is going to exit
just wants to tear him down and release
information that makes him look
terrible, okay?
Continuing on. Continuing on, okay?
Continuing on. Dude, okay.
My best friend was at my house and
thought I was a victim from the jump. He
was also saying similar stuff, all cool,
so she started recording. At the end of
the night rape, you can barely hear her
whisper, "You were a victim, lol."
Agree.
I was only playing along because I don't
know what Oh, sorry.
Um
Agree, I was only playing along because
I don't know what else to say. Also, I
talked to him because both emo with
similar interests, I thought, but turns
out we had nothing in common and he
listens to bad emo music, lol. Also, was
only involved with Jet stuff because I
don't know, I'm a hot girl online who's
in the same evil spheres, so they tend
to orbit to me. Abby exposed Jet on my
behalf, lol, over bitterness. I didn't
even know who Ellie was or the whole
drama there. I guess I accidentally
opened that wormhole. Right, okay.
Okay. And now, ladies and gentlemen,
okay? We come to
a very funny revelation.
So, as you know, recently Aiden has been
involved in some controversy of their
own, okay?
Now,
he decided to use this as an opportunity
to go on the attack.
Okay? [laughter]
So, Aiden started to leak.
And just for the purposes of
transparency, Aiden also did leak this
to me, bro.
Cuz you know, after I called the other
day, I sort of sent him a message and
was like, "Listen, man, you know,
nothing personal, don't hate you, but
some of your behavior is quite [__]
nuclear, so I'm I'm, you know, I can't I
can't really be seen along side of that.
Not that I really talk to Aiden that
much anymore anyway, but I just made it
clear like, nothing personal,
professional courtesy, whatever, right?
But we obviously were having a bit of a
back and forth about this cuz it was so
funny. Because it was so funny that like
this dropped just after his controversy.
Literally saved Literally saved by this.
Classic instance of drama leaking, okay?
That benefits you, right? Dude, it's so
[laughter] good, man.
Um so, yeah, anyway, I I'll just show
you my comment on this on this, too.
Right? I'll just show you my little
thoughts on this, right?
So, this is what my kind of
take on it was yesterday.
Dude, Aiden could have literally raped
and murdered LeoK voice's wife and the
story would push that out of the
headlines. Is that not real Is that not
real? Is that not real, dude?
Oh my god, dude.
Dude, absolutely insane bit of luck for
Aiden, okay?
Sorry, guys. Aiden Projects I had to AFK
from the chat. It's not enough to sit by
idly. He must
>> I did say before I left, just to be
clear. Okay?
So,
he then started to leak.
Claims from YouTuber Aiden Projects
about Kai and Tom. [__] it, dude, I'm
leaking. Kai is into age play. Lyrics
told me when he first broke up with her.
Oh, oh no, what?
>> [gasps]
>> Oh my god, bro, what is going on?
Dude.
Okay.
And further from that,
Lyrics confided in me like 2 years ago
at that point that Kai likes to pretend
to be a little girl during sex and did
this with Tom. That's why I went so
insane when Lyrics got back with her.
No.
Oh, no.
Okay.
So, listen, guys, okay? I know Aiden's
got a rough ride recently for some of
his little tricks and and sort of little
little lies.
>> [laughter]
>> I don't know how Chad or anyone thinks
that this benefits Aiden.
Augie already covered it.
Nick wasn't going to cover this [__]
Who else was going to cover this?
Everyone covered Aiden's drama that was
going to cover Aiden's drama
and still going to get brought up all
the time that he doxxed Laura convoys
wife. Like, I don't know what people
think has changed from this drama coming
out. It's a very
[__] reading.
Hey.
Right? Yeah, and now he just looks like
a total rat and Liam is probably mad at
him.
Like,
wow, great stuff Wow.
But,
I think this is true. I'm going to just
say I reckon this is true. I I am like,
okay. I would I'd be very hard-pressed
to believe
The battle lines have shifted. It's us
versus pedophiles. I was never against
Aiden in the first place. Yeah, I I like
Aiden regardless of whether he's done
bad stuff, you know, I've
So, I've said many times I've said my
stance many times. I just think you
should accurately describe the people
you associate with and you shouldn't
sweep for them and all this stuff. I
don't think you have to cut people off
over every specific thing.
So, I was never like, you know, [__]
Aiden, Aiden's done.
You know, but the reality is
he [__] up. He did something bad.
Everyone knows he did it. It's been
covered and it's going to keep getting
brought up.
And he's [__] himself in that respect.
That.
This is [__] I just don't think
it's like It just seems
This is true, guys. This is true, okay?
I think Kai's into age play. I think Tom
did it. I think Lyrics did it.
The The only possible saving grace is
that Tom was just going along with it.
And that, yes, is probably a bit of
sweeping, but I'm just putting it out.
It's possible.
Maybe Tom was just going along with it,
guys, hey? Maybe he was Maybe he wasn't
really that into it.
And more importantly,
does it not also lend weight to some of
the Lyrics stuff?
Oh,
oh no, dude.
This is
Oh, man. This is you know, this is Yeah,
we are
Okay. We We are in the endgame. We are
in the endgame, ladies and gentlemen.
Oh, boy. Dude, Jesus.
Okay.
Um so, your past around e-thot. I never
met Jet IRL or any four channel freak,
but Tom, lol. So, I I I'll be honest
with you, you guys might know about the
Jet Neptune stuff. That's a bit out of
my remit here. I don't really know about
that, but take from that,
you know, what you will, I guess. Take
from that what you will.
Take from that what you will.
Wait, Stylo, I'm get No spoilers. No
spoilers, okay? I'm going to go through
the document and then I'll bring it up,
okay?
I think it might come up in a bit. Let's
see.
Okay. Okay.
She dated him longer, so Okay, besides
the age play [__] can you tell us
any about any weird [__] he's also into?
She dated him longer, so she might have
more insight, lol, but to me, just weird
CNC [__] forced play again into small
girls and down near age play. He would
just talk about rape a lot.
Who would do that, bro?
Who would do that? What sort of
deranged, insane person would do that?
Oh dear. Oh dear.
Tell us about time he cried, lmao. I'm
back. Tom only cried at Sopranos movies.
Okay, well, that's based.
Why didn't you go on [__] tank? Wasn't
allowed, various reasons. Kato got on me
through though. [__] tank is fish is a
fish tank spin-off series.
Wage War, Alpha Wolf, A Day To Remember.
Okay, I don't know these bands. Wage
War, Alpha Wolf, A Day To Remember, only
bands we had in common. Listen to a lot
of new age slop.
What did Tom's living space look like?
Was it messy? Did he have empty cans and
bottles everywhere? Did he do anything
weird?
He had piles of dirty zines piled up
like little volcanoes. Yes, empty cans
and bottles everywhere.
Okay.
Now we get a bit more juice. You think
You think the orange has been
extinguished,
but there's always a little bit more
juice in the squeeze, ladies and
gentlemen, okay?
I don't know what we are
The meow and stuff kind of sucks. Is
that a score being like involved in Jet
Neptune stuff? There's these photos of
her,
I guess, where she's posing in a
[__] lolly shirt and she's doing
like kids clothing and that sort of
[__] She just kind of e-look lined. It
looks kind of e-look lined there. Do you
know what I mean?
I'm getting I'm getting e-look lined
here.
Do you guys see what I mean?
Yeah, I think everyone sees it. Okay.
Start around here.
>> It's called Soy because a lot of
problems with people sexting and
e-fucking on there, which is incredibly
ironic considering that's public now.
Nicholas Yerian Twitter.
Nick just responded. Oh, just to be
clear, I've seen literally nothing of
what's occurred tonight, but my
understanding is that Half Baked is on
haters for a little while, so we'll see
in the next couple of days where that
goes. Okay. And then there's a clip
there. Nick Fuentes half baked his
podcast with Tommy and Lord Vega is
going on hiatus for a while, but it
could be DM's. Here's the thing with
this, okay? Anyone that wants to claim
that this is a nothingburger, okay?
Why the [__] is the podcast going on
hiatus, dude? That makes zero [__]
sense, bro.
That makes zero sense, okay?
If this is nothing to worry about,
nothing to be concerned about, okay? Why
is the podcast going on hiatus, okay?
Now, could someone
while we watch this
please
arrange in chronological order
all of the Nicholas relevant Nicholas
Dorio Discord messages
that happened during this Chud coverage.
Go, please. Thank you.
Listen, I will be fair. I know what
people in chat thinking and they're
going to say, okay?
But my concern, ladies and gentlemen, is
the big sweep might be on, okay? The mid
the big sweep might be on.
Okay? The big sweep. I am not
participating in the big sweep, okay?
This is a totally legitimate story to
cover and talk about. And that's the end
of it, bro. And if anyone disagrees, if
anyone thinks I'm doing something wrong,
we'll talk about it, okay? Happy to talk
about it.
But there is literally nothing more to
>> who who might have an issue with this?
Who might have an issue with this, Chud?
Who do you think might have a problem
with this? I don't think they'll be
calling in somehow.
about this and talking about this.
This is completely legitimate. And
obviously, if Turkey Tom
makes videos using Kiwi Farms as a
source, okay? It's totally legitimate of
obviously
to make comments about it. Without
question, bro, okay? Now, I don't think
Listen, guys, okay?
I do not believe that people have got
obligation to cover anything. People can
cover what they want, okay?
But my question would be
what would the coverage be like if this
is about iDubbbz? If it was revealed
that iDubbbz that that Anisa was into
age play and [__] like that, what would
the coverage be? And I think the answer
to that tells you everything that you
need to know, doesn't it?
>> [laughter]
>> But nonetheless
I'm not making any firm claims.
I don't know what's going to happen. I
can't predict the future.
I can't predict the future, guys, okay?
But to me, you can look at who decides
to talk about this and who doesn't. And
that will give you an indication of what
Sorry, guys. I'm going to have to side
with Tom here. The woman is busted,
chopped, goat cat or S.
She's mentally ill. I'll not rubber
stamp something so clearly below my
standards. You want to co-sign? Ask
Cayden. I hear he likes this sort of
build.
Okay.
Thank you, Jimbly, for the $50.
Huge generous of you, Jimbly.
Thank you so much.
I totally agree with the assessment of
Aiden's taste.
what the deal is. Yeah, there's there's
some real there's some real commentary
sevens.
Some real commentary sevens floating
around right now.
That's going to tell you everything you
need to know.
>> [laughter]
>> Dude, are we getting to the actual meat
and potatoes here, dude? I don't care
about any of this [__] bro. Where's the
[__] meat and potatoes?
Where's the [__] meat and potatoes,
dude? Is it coming up? Here we go. Here
we go. This is it. Creepy hoarder
Shiruusa.
The girl Okay,
I think we're getting to the actual good
bits now.
The girl he sent dick pics to and got
hacked was an age play Belle Delphine
type girl. I sent the screenshots about
the blackmailer guy here earlier. He
told me he went to meet up with her, but
was too weirded out and went back home.
>> This is worse MD5s,
dude. Her account has been posted in
this thread before. I believe it's
creepy hoarder.
So, this.
Ooh.
Um
>> [laughter]
>> Oh, NO,
DUDE.
NO.
NO, BRO. NO.
UH-OH. Not looking good, guys. It's not
looking good, guys.
What is this?
What is this, dude?
Check out the story highlights Tommy's
done for and it's this.
Okay, wait a second. Slow down. Slow
down.
What is the kind of evidence here? What
is the evidence like backup to this?
Do you know what I mean?
Like I What I mean is What's the
connection? So, apparently this person
got hacked and Tommy's got communication
with them. Is that what we're
understanding here?
But where's the Where's that?
Check out the story highlights Tommy's
done for.
I also remember being posted on LC in
the ego cows thread.
This image in particular is huge for
lolicon egos. I've seen this on
different threads and a lot more of
notable similar cows
use this image passing off as them.
Control F the name Ellie, creepy
hoarder, or Shiruusa for more.
Okay.
Okay, what is this now, dude?
Censored because she's dressed like a
kid. Oh, no, dude.
But wait.
Do we have proof that these two are in
communication together? They're in
concert.
Like this looks terrible, but what's the
evidence to back up they're talking?
Also, sorry. Can someone please send me
this photo uncensored? Not because Not
for any other reason than I Yeah, again,
this is like a hypocrisy playing, right?
This is like
you know you you then call this [__] so
disgusting until it's a bit until it's a
bit you want to [__]
And then all of a sudden it all uh
who gives a [__]
I want to check and see
what it is because this could I I you
know, that's not my opinion. That's the
person that's wrote this.
Where is it? Dude.
Bro.
Okay, I can't see it here, man.
I can't see it here, dude.
Okay, anyway.
Extra screenshots.
At Sacramento89, sent me two pictures of
self with Turkey Tom and other self by
herself with a note and fashion
accessory that matches the photos with
TT, okay?
So, that is apparently null verifying
that.
Okay.
Um
Yes, this is the full picture.
>> That's a bluey t-shirt, ladies and
gentlemen.
I mean
>> [snorts]
>> That's That's not good. That's not look
That's not look so good. That doesn't
look so good.
The only piece of the puzzle that we're
missing
is
some sort of evidence of communication.
I'm not seeing that here.
Tom hitting girl in a diaper and a bib.
Not true.
Oh, but yeah, guys. There we go. There
we go.
And we got some other stuff here.
Okay, what is this?
Okay.
Okay, interesting. I mean, we got she's
a widow. We get it. understanding then
is that Tom
This is a
is It just feels like Tommy's getting
more grace because he's Turkey Tom. Like
I don't Oh, here we go. Here we go. We
need this.
story.
I know there's more. I know there's
more. This is a dude, this is a quickly
developing story, okay? This is a
quickly developing story.
I've had some more materials posted.
You think Tom did anything egregious of
a 19 to 21-year-old?
I mean
this is like very embarrassing and this
age play stuff is
like dude, I just feel like there's the
Is that not an instinctive kind of like
sweep? Is that not just like a sweep?
Like come on, what's the big deal? I
mean
it just feels like Tommy's getting more
grace because he's Turkey Tom. Like I
don't know what I just get this feeling
that people are looking at this and
they're looking at it with the
perspective of Oh, it's Turkey Tom
though.
Like come on. Like I'm not saying this
is the end of the world. I'm not saying
he's a rake. I'm not saying he's, you
know, the worst person ever.
But there's this instinctive desire to
like just just kind of be like Oh, it's
not that big a deal. It's a
nothingburger. You know, there's
something there. There's something in
there. It's not the end of the world.
It's not the worst thing. It's just
There's something a bit odd and weird
here. So
>> [clears throat]
>> let's start looking at some of these.
So, Chud's talking about how, you know,
you can see by who doesn't cover it and
this sort of thing.
And you know, obviously Nick may cover
it. Nick may cover it. He He may not
have chosen to cover it that night.
You know?
But let's be honest. If it didn't like
catch traction, if it didn't become a
big thing he would absolutely just move
on.
Right? He would absolutely He would
overlook it if he could.
Obviously obviously the case, you know,
we we've seen him do it many times
before.
So, let's take a look at some of these
Discord messages.
Let's see.
>> [clears throat]
>> So, there's people here talking. So,
Chud's better than Sive Sive. He's
joking. That's clearly serious. Here in
Valkyrie doing age play with love.
It's talking about the idea that they
would cover it if it was Sisona or
whatever.
We'd laugh if you crazy say he's a pedo,
but they're calling him pedo for other
things already. But
no one's calling Tom a pedo. I mean,
some retards are, but Chud certainly
wasn't.
Any updates, Mr. Logic? You say that.
And then Nick goes
Nah.
I don't think that was a joke, lol.
This [__] It ain't that serious, Nick.
I'm I'm crying. I'm crying.
So, then Nick says
I'm so confused at his comment reading
into why the podcast is on hiatus. He
knows I was live streaming for the
majority of the time the thread was
being written  discussed, right?
So
What That doesn't matter. What did Chud
say about the podcast being on hiatus?
He said
for anyone saying that this is a
nothingburger
all you have to do is ask yourself why
is the podcast on hiatus?
That's not a comment on why Nick
whether Nick covered it or whether Nick
was streaming when it came out.
That's not That's not the point here.
Like this guy is such a dishonest
[__] [__] [__]
He just sits around in his gay little
members-only Discord
just lying about the criticisms people
are making up about him
to try and gas himself up with a bunch
of [__] losers with mental
disabilities like Grizzly.
This is a criticism I actually have of
Aiden. Aiden kind of does this, too.
Um
but we know all all that aside from
that.
Now
are we talking about this?
I saw someone posting something.
Yeah, I saw this get posted. So, the
thing is this
is is is it in
it isn't here, right?
One minute, sorry. Sorry, one I just
have to check something.
Oh, yeah. So, this website got found.
It's called uh [clears throat]
the Oreos.Rodeo.
I don't know why it's called Rodeo. I
don't know why it could be a reference
uh but
it's called the the Oreos.Rodeo.
And you you can just go and see
Nick DeOrio's Discord.
It's live up to the minute, up to the
second.
And it's uh it's got Nick DeOrio's
Discord. You can just go browse through
the channels and see what they're saying
and you can get them in time.
I think that's pretty neat.
I think that's pretty neat. Some of it
isn't
>> Sorry, wait. We were going through
screenshots still.
So
that's just I I just like I like that
because I really don't like this idea
that people have these gay little gated
Discord chats.
Yeah, it's like Russell search. Like the
it's like the
the Destiny stuff.
I I don't like the idea that people have
these gay little gated chats where they
let some of their fans in
and they just sit there coping and
bitching and lying.
So, I I do think that's pretty neat that
that exists.
So, yeah. This is just like a total
misrepresentation of the statement that
was being made cuz he's like a total
avoidant [__] [__]
who will never like
address criticism head-on.
And then that's followed up with this.
You guys don't get how funny this is,
lol.
Oh, guys. I
I guess none none of this [__] say this
[__] ain't nothing to me, bro.
I'm crying.
This [__] nothing to me, bro.
This [__] noth- This [__] nothing to me,
bro. It's so funny.
I had a falling out with Chud
literally around 2:00 p.m. yesterday.
So,
it's a bunch of cat laughing at my
reacts.
What's that about?
So, then So, next thing here, I had a
So, he's saying it's so funny.
So, this [__] nothing to me, bro.
I'm crying.
This [__] nothing to me, bro.
But he had a falling out with Chud
yesterday.
If it's so If you're so like If this
situation is just funny
then why are you getting in your
feelings, getting into arguments with
people behind the scenes?
Yeah, I thought they fell out a while
ago. I didn't I didn't really realize
they still had much communication, to be
honest. I guess it's Nick DeOrio being
um you know, we all see what's going on
there, right? We It like takes It
doesn't take a [__] genius here.
Nick literally is leaked as talking mad
[__] about about Chud
to Tommy, to Tom, to Willie
probably to Augie
talks crazy [__]
behind his back.
But then because Nick is a
image-obsessed narcissistic lazy [__]
[__]
he decides that what he has to do is go
around to any content creator that he
thinks he can get his foot in the door
with. ain't nothing to me. Happy cat
face emoji. Happy cat face emoji. Happy
cat face emoji. I had a falling out with
Chud. Pouting cat face emoji. Pouting
cat face emoji. Pouting cat face emoji.
Thank you for the 999 general. Thank
you. I do appreciate it. Cuz he's a
total avoidant [__] who's obsessed with
his image.
He will maintain contact with Chud even
after he's like kicked him out of the
house in his head
because that keeps Chud inside the tent
pissing out
rather than outside the tent pissing in.
He feels like as long as he
strings along with enough like pretense
that they might still be friends without
outright uh confronting the the
the issue they have
then he can maintain his image. He can
save face. He doesn't have to look like
a sensitive [__] [__] who's freaking
out cuz Chud said, you know, you you you
suck Ethan Klein's dick,
you know?
He doesn't have to admit that he's
breaking up a friendship cuz someone
said he's a Ethan Klein dick rider,
you know?
It's like so apparent. Yeah, and he does
that exactly. He goes into Chud's chat
to present that image, too.
Cuz he's trying to tell people like,
"Look, guys. I'm
This is still like my my sort of area.
I'm still around here, guys."
So, then he says, "Nothing serious. I'm
not going to litigate it. But wow,
today's take seems a little more
critical. Haha."
He didn't see today's take. This [__]
wasn't out at 2:00 p.m. yesterday.
So, what happened at 2:00 p.m.
yesterday?
What happened at 2:00 p.m. yesterday?
Cuz this [__] went out.
So, I am having a thought. Maybe it's
not the New Year's stream. Maybe it's
just New Year's.
Maybe it's just you're going to always
have these problems if you're a wretched
avoidant [__] [__] who tries to
present an image of himself on the
internet that you can't back up.
Maybe that's the issue, Nick. Maybe the
issue is
that you're a cynical dishonest
[__] wretch.
And so, you're going to constantly have
these issues
where you look bad and freak out.
Maybe that's the case.
Maybe it's not New Year's.
Maybe it's not a New Year's stream.
Maybe it's you.
Maybe not doing the New Year's stream is
not preventing the New Year's well.
Great stuff. So, yeah. Those are the
main Discord messages there.
So, uh
I want I need this leaked. Okay, I need
this leaked. I need this leaked now.
They had a falling out at 2:00 p.m.
yesterday.
So, yeah. I've seen people say this. I
just don't want to
say anything because I don't want to
like, you know,
what if I say, "Yeah, I think it is
that."
And then it turns out being something
like crazy where Chud's in the wrong,
you know?
But 2:00 p.m. yesterday does line up
roughly
with like that clip going around of
Pisco talking about Nick blocking him.
And Chud like makes a joke in response
being like
yeah, he does that or some [__] That is
around when that was happening.
2:00 p.m. in New York around
that would have been what?
Evening in the UK, obviously.
The debate was at 3:00 p.m.
to 5:30. I think that would have been
about 7:00 2:00 p.m. New York. So, the
timeline makes sense.
No, Stahli. You don't know what I'm
saying.
You're [__] up time zones.
You're wrong. You're wrong.
I [clears throat] already did the the
fact-checking here, okay?
You said, "No, no, no." But everything I
said was right. So, if you're
disagreeing If you're If you're
disagreeing then then you're wrong
cuz I'm right. Cuz I checked this.
2:00 p.m. New York
fight is uh 7:00 p.m. UK.
The debate was 3:00 p.m. UK
to 5:30 p.m. UK.
And the clip would have been getting
traction afterwards.
That's all true. So, it it does all line
up.
But it would be
literally
totally [__] insane
if they fell out over that clip.
That is like next-level
thin-skinned [__] [__] [__] from
Nick if that's the case.
So, I'm hesitant cuz it's almost too
good to be true.
But I need it leaked. I need it leaked.
Otherwise I'm just going to start making
stuff up.
I'm going to say they both
confided in each other about their sex
crimes and had an argument about who the
bigger pedophile was.
I'm just going to start making [__] up
unless one of them leaks it. isn't
verified. Some of it isn't confirmed and
there isn't evidence for some of the
claims.
But let me ask you this. Let me ask you
this, okay? Let me ask you this.
If Turkey Tom released a documentary or
video with these claims about someone
else what would you be saying? Would you
be like the perspective you got in your
head? Or would you be like, "Yeah, this
person is a bit of a weirdo at the very
least." Like come on, bro.
You know? Now, that being said, there
isn't good evidence for some of these
claims and I will wait for more
information. Okay?
But, you know, I mean, I'll go back to
the iDubbz example.
If it was claimed that Anisa was into
age play, okay, and iDubbz was playing
along what would your thought process
be? Would it be, "No big deal." Would it
be, "Oh my god, that's crazy. iDubbz is
embarrassed again. Blah blah blah blah."
You know?
Oh, Sofa King.
>> Dude, my throat is really starting to
strain. I'm not going to lie. We're
going to go for as long as I can,
though. the record for the absolute most
endless [__] takes in chat, dude.
Have I not been fair?
Have I not been fair in this, dude? At
every step of the way, I presented
alternatives, different positions,
different views. What am I saying that
is not fair, dude? It is obvious that
Turkey Tom is getting grace because he's
Turkey Tom. Tell me I'm wrong.
Tell me I'm [__] wrong, bro.
Give me a [__] break, right? With
this pissing on my boots tell me it's
raining [__]
Okay?
He is obviously getting grace from
people cuz it's
It's so [__] transparent. And people
are acting like, you know, drama's dry.
Sorry. Sorry that you're so jaded that a
million sub commentary guy, someone I
used to knock about with back in the day
until he apparently had some problem
with me, right? I'm sorry that
embarrassing details of his relationship
getting leaked is not particularly
interesting to you.
Okay?
But this is a big story. This is a big
[__] story, dude. Okay?
Give me a [__] break, dude. Okay?
And if I, you know,
if I have to hash this out with someone,
I will hash it out with someone, okay? I
mean, Augie would probably be the
person. And Augie is the one with the
who's still got the balls to actually
have a [__] conversation on stream
about this [__] okay?
But I'm not saying it's the worst thing
in the world. I'm not saying that this
is like destructive or whatever. There's
lots of claims that are unevidenced and
I'd want to see more evidence.
Okay.
But there's a story here
and I think that there's this
instinctive desire to sweep it away
because it's Turkey Tom.
And people want to come into this and be
like, oh come on, it's not that big a
deal.
Bro, okay, dude, I I wrestled Weaves and
nailed it. Forget the Idubbbz thing. No,
this is the take. This is the take,
dude. This is it. This is the take, bro.
What if Hasan [__] was exposed for
potentially liking age play?
That is the [__] take, dude. That is
the [__] take, bro.
Come on now.
Let's be [__] realistic here. That's
the take, isn't it?
You [__] know that I'm right. You
know, deep down in your heart, that I am
correct about this.
And that's it.
That's all you need to say.
That's is all you need to say.
Okay.
Let's have a little look.
I think we need some further
supplementary information here.
Okay, what is this that I'm being
linked? I'm being linked these random
tweets. What are you What are you
sending me here, dude?
What are you sending me here?
Suppose you're not talking
Okay.
Not the back of this, but I
I don't know. The tail.
Come on, man.
>> [laughter]
>> I mean, what are we saying? Is this Is
this indicative of the uh the
relationship?
Is that what's going on?
Is that the situation?
Yo, testify. Yo, dude, perfect. I'd
rather talk to
I just want to see your take on this. I
want to hear what you've got to say.
No pressure, obviously.
I'll just have a piece about it, so
interested to hear your take if you so
wish.
Bro.
There is a weird energy here, right?
Like they're kind of like
quite flirtatious, you know, I did.
>> [laughter]
>> There's a certainly a flirtatious energy
here.
Joseph I think his people going to
Well, how can I talk about this, bro?
How dude? Okay, bro.
But the big ones are all going to read
everything live, say it's bad and drop
him instantly.
Watch that not happen. And also, I don't
think this is dude, I'm not even saying
at this stage it's bad enough to drop
him over.
Like, bro, dude.
How, dude? One of the most frustrating
things about doing this is not being
understood, man. I've laid it out as
clearly as I can, okay?
It's very obvious that Turkey Tom will
get grace on this that wouldn't be given
to other creators, okay?
Because you could, you know, make a
video about Hasan doing this and Right,
you get it. It's simple. It's It's
simple to understand.
Like, I'm not I'm not saying that you
should cut off Tom for this even, right?
That's not what I'm saying at all. It's
just, you know, my thought process here
is that he is, as we speak, getting more
grace. There's people in chat that are
coming in and insisting it's a nothing
burger. And it's like, look, I don't
think it's particularly compelling as it
stands cuz there's lots of stuff that
isn't evidenced.
Right? It's just why is your instinct to
sweep? Because I feel Dude,
wait a second, dude. Wait a second.
Wasn't there something with this
recently? I didn't really follow it cuz
it's [__] Hasan related.
And I don't care. I don't [__] care,
okay?
>> [laughter]
>> Shut up. Listen, okay? Listen, it's not
happening. It's not [__] happening,
dude. It's not [__] happening, okay?
Crewman, you [__] little rats.
It ain't happening, bro. It ain't
happening, okay? I'm telling you.
No, I'll leave it Listen, okay? Listen,
>> [laughter]
>> you little rats.
Listen, okay?
>> [laughter]
>> Bro, bro.
Bro.
Dude.
Okay, anyway, this stuff is not even
that big a deal. Guys, this is nothing
to me, okay? This is nothing to me. This
[__] is nothing to me.
I'll give you a [__] break, dude.
Give me a [__] break.
Give me a [__] break, man.
Anyway, anyway, what [laughter] was I
saying, dude? This [__] ain't serious,
bro. This [__] ain't serious, bro.
>> [snorts]
>> Anyway, what was I saying? Oh, [__] off.
[__] you. [__] you, bro.
[__] you, dude.
[__] you.
Anyway, dude, you left my train of
thought. My train of thought was raped.
I think that if, you know, there was
something to do with Hasan and I think
he apparently claimed to be a a furry
claimed he was a furry or something.
And [snorts] some people were pushing it
without, you know,
some people were pushing it without it
being verified or something like that.
And it's like that's the kind of energy
that some people bring to Hasan. It's
like instantaneous Oh, we might lose it.
You're instantaneously pushing
something, but like there's this stuff
about Turkey Tom and it's all
nothing burger, no big deal, you know,
[__] like that.
I just did. I just [__] did, bro.
>> [laughter]
>> Whoa!
No way, dude.
Lyrics? Lyrics?
Lyrics?
I'm seeing clips of like how many subs I
lose. Bro,
okay.
We were
>> [laughter]
>> We were popping off a bit, okay? We were
popping off a little bit earlier. We
were popping off.
It's all good now. We're nice and calm
now. We're relaxed now. We're nice and
relaxed, dude.
Um
Wild Turkey Tom, thank you for the super
chats.
Rubishka with the $10, guilty. He's
guilty. He's got crimes against women
for all of you. Thank you for the $10.
Thank you.
Slug with the dollar, you have a die
commentary YouTuber or live long enough
to become a low cow. First Aiden
becoming the new notorious doxer and now
Turkey Tom facing destiny allegations.
Thank you for the dollar. And yo, Tippy,
if you're still here, hope you're well,
Tip Tippy. Thank you.
Repent Chad, there is still time. I can
still grant you a pardon from the wrath
of the Tippy curse. Thank you for the
super chat.
Super toaster, thank you for the $5. Oh,
she's an MD girl, okay, this all adds
up. She really is passed around e-coli
mouth. Thank you. I think I'm going to
read this one. I'm not taking another
friend behind the shed. Thank you for
the super chat.
Thank you for the $10. The pot is over.
It's done. Knox is gone. Thank you. The
Geo X war with $5. This is the second
commentary spur guy in a row. Fortress
arc when? I'm not Listen, the fortress
arc
not that Well,
is it fortress arc? I don't know what we
call it.
What are we going to call it? The The
table arc. The table incident arc.
Sadly, your rape is over. Thank you for
the gifted sub. Thank you. TBIR arc.
Thank you.
Anyway, let's just go ahead and crack on
with these. Would it be fair to call
Tommy G riffer to never going merch?
That's worse than the hypocrisy. I don't
really think so. I don't I don't think
it's that deep. Thank you. Dude films
ready the weirdo dog person we see him
here to freak off with her.
What's the logic here? Thank you for the
$5. Thank you 89 square for 245 pound.
Thank you for that.
Love on the spectrum American edition.
Thank you for the $2. Flip flop. Do you
think Dickinson and Queenan acted like
this IRL?
Who was trained up? Thank you for the
super chat.
>> Okay, that's wonderful. Also, I need to
do I I I woke up actually cuz I do need
to pay my
Dude, it's bro, it's happening. I'm
paying my deposit to my place. Yo, dude.
I'm actually doing it. I'm finally doing
it. I'm actually going to be paying my
deposit.
Isn't that insane?
Isn't that crazy? So, I could I could do
that now before I go go and do the
school run.
Yes, bro. The quarter house is coming,
dude. after press people. Remember to
spray and neuter your dogs. Thank you
for the super chat.
Leo Archivist, ready to get this long
sought after date with Ego. Thank you.
Thank you. Nice one. Yeah, I've seen
that. Thank you.
What are you going to complain about
now? No more mortgage talk. God forbid.
Well, I mean, a lot of stuff getting
rectified in my personal life.
Is uh you know
is yet to make me feel a lot more.
Locked in, you know?
Yeah, it's good. It's good. We're
laughing.
Anyway, guys, thank you very much for
the support. Much appreciated. Sorry for
the short stream today. Dude, my next
couple of days are kind of raped. As
I've said, Gramps is
you know
any day any any moment any moment now.
You are next. What does that mean?
Dude, I was never married in the first
place, dude.
Well, I mean, you know, when someone is
old
it takes a while for them to pass away.
But, they're just waiting in the
hospital.
They should Gramps want to stop hitting.
Come on, bro. That is out of order.
Uh the Gramps stuff here. We we don't
need the Gramps stuff. Great stuff.
Okay.
Awesome stuff there. Awesome stuff
there.